all the material in this video is actual
captured gameplay footage running on
Xbox one I'm some lake from remedy today
you're gonna see quantum breaks time
amplified action gameplay as well as the
unreleased adventuring gameplay inside a
stutter in time yeah about that
bad news her current theme of the night
I'm looking at the bridge right now it's
getting tense out there
if I go anywhere near that thing will be
people crossbars all right
yeah there's a peer under the bridge
should be able to meet me there with the
boat giant gas sign out front canvas
it's nice and bright for monarch to see
not a lot of options here I'm gonna
switch to the monarch frequency text me
if you need anything
few minutes this sequence is from the
midpoint in the game jack is trying to
reunite with our other hero Beth Wilder
but monarch is standing between him and
his goal quanto break is an intense
story driven action game spectacle a
dream about University a failed time
travel experiment goes horribly wrong
time starts to break down Chuck choice
our hero is caught in the blast of the
failed experiment he gains the power to
manipulate time he's fighting this
thought the end of time and time is
literally running out in the case of the
failed experiment Jack's best friend
Paul serene disappears into the time
machine and soon after he's 17 years
older a ruthless fanatical head of a
corporation called monarch solutions
jack is an obstacle to Serene's plans
best friends turned mortal enemies to
make things worse the fracture in time
is getting more and more unstable
some lucky Joe let us search his truck
you work serene we take the hard line
easy on the trigger finger but if it
comes to it Gaby
that was a short stutter in time a sign
of time breaking down foreshadowing
things to come
that's the monarch HQ you can see in the
skyline there
shut up
Check Point team moving target has been
spotted on the fridge aging party
anybody see him just advance
gotta get to that peer check and rust
routine becoming just a blur to confuse
and strike his enemies he can even stop
bullets and then release them for
maximum impact we've got a visual on
Joyce
anybody
when Chucky uses time powers the enemies
lose track of him resulting in exciting
cat-and-mouse game play each cue we've
got eyes on the pier keep your sights on
that dock he may try to escape by water
[ __ ]
it's cue the civvies heard gunfire
they're freaking out up here
all time powers are easy and fun to
learn in the beginning and we are adding
more power and more depth into the mix
as the challenge Scrolls that appears
too hot I'm gonna find another way
across
I'm almost there wait I'm not doing
Sofia hid risk I'll make it across that
bridge whatever it takes
we've got civvies trying to push through
the line you know your orders hardline
any means necessary
in quantum break time is stuttering and
breaking down entirely
to the world at large this crisis is
hidden when time stops everybody freezes
but Jax powers let him function inside
the stutter check and at control
stutters he must navigate through their
dangers to survive
monarch solutions have developed
technology that allows their elite
troops to operate inside stutters
pushing the threat to a new level
these cronin tech juggernauts have
heavy-duty exoskeletons and custom-built
weapons
check can also use time powers to
release key objects and characters
inside stutters in one of our earlier
demos we saw him release a scientist
Sophia a morel from a stature here he
does it to a car frozen in meat crash
and uses it as a weapon against the
enemy in a stutter things try to revert
to their initial state this includes the
released objects smaller objects you can
move around even hazards like cars that
explode you can blow them up but the
explosion freezes and rewinds these
things can be used as weapons either by
you or against you
repeatedly
final stretch
Oh
the stutters in time manifest as frozen
moments that can shift and collapse
without warning or time lines caught in
violent destructive loops crashing into
each other
stutters are absolutely unstable hostile
environments you have to use your time
powers to survive and you have to use
them in a different way from how you use
them in combat
here we go
that I hope gives you an idea of what to
expect from quantum breaks time
amplified action gameplay quanta break
is coming out in 2050 thank you only on
Xbox one